hey guys what's up I'm Ilana welcome to
my Channel today we're playing halo 2
anniversary as part of the master chief
collection on the xbox one by playing
gory of mind today I'm pretty sure this
one starts out with a cutscene but i
should say i haven't weirdest how to
play halo 2 e-mail but ever I barely
remember it so i'm actually just really
excited to get into this i do even this
though what I look so pretty you
unattractive no offense relax I'd rather
not piss this thing off good logic
you need fresh temper and has my to
conclude look how gorgeous it looks like
this is halo 2 or like a shaming and is
the more kill me or release me parasite
but do not waste my time with talk there
is no really looking at a state not the
time no I shall talk you okay please
don't kill me ah 2401 intention of
installation 05 o prophet of aggression
nice earrings brick here we have much to
do this facility must be activated if we
are to control this outbreak stay where
you are nothing can be done until my
servant is complete not true this
installation is why it is so nice we've
done an amazing job of this cutscene
specifically all the objects our Lord
left behind there are none so worthless
is these Oracle's they know nothing of
the great journey no nothing oh snap
nothing this one's good too
and this one's great Charlie are the
same as here you know profits have
promised you freedom from a human
existence but you will find no salvation
on this equals x holes do a lot to
Masonic their intent or I'll will perish
as they did okay this thing is right
halo is a weapon your profits are making
a big mistake your ignorance already
destroyed one of the sacred rings demon
shall not hominem if you will not hear
the truth that I any bread there is
still time to spot the key from turning
but first it must be found you will
search one likely spot will perish
another fate had us meet as foes but
this ring will make are we ready for the
shitty times think we are you see the
prophet saw something
man the graphics are crazy so awesome
they nailed it we are all of us gravely
concerned the release of the parasite
was unexpected unfortunate but there is
no need to panic and truth this is a
time to rejoice a moment but i do love
seeing the Covenant like this for the
sacred icon has been found with it our
path is clear our entry into the divine
beyond guarantee icing the depth of
great journeys I like his little chin
dangly bits not even the fog divas doc
so cute kill the demon I always liked
that as well for some reason when they
call Master Chief the demon I can
understand them thinking he's a demon
okay we're gonna need to change the
control scheme here I think button
layout
okay that sounds about right no what
should be fine all right that's where
you can kill those roof the better yes
well I'm working on it thanks go down
take them out before alrighty um I think
sit oh hey friend I know a lil exploit
um the graphics that's the thing i want
to do look how different it looks it's
amazing oh I don't think so okay where
am I going vaguely this direction seems
correct but I don't actually know how to
get out of here well checkpoint Don
that's some oh hey buddy have any
grenades nope damn it I'm just gonna do
that all the time oh so cool yeah but
really like I mean I played a lot of
halo 2 online but didn't play as much of
the campaign where is some of the other
halo games when I was younger I'd replay
them all the time maybe because I didn't
have an internet connection I don't
remember my reasoning for it but so I
like Bailey remember this and it's kind
of nice because while i really liked
ODST and I mean reach was quite good I
do still think that halo 1 and 2 in my
head were like the best halo game so
it's look so oh oh my god did I just
died oh my god
Wow okay that was not expected
all right good
but ya know it's it's nice to be able to
play through one of the first Halo games
and not really remember it like you know
instead of I would prefer to get to
replay this than to play a new halo game
it where is he something's are false /
you stressed me up stop it so charging
at me are you doing can't see you all
right yeah that makes me stand out
better yeah all right that wasn't so
hard put me down on one of the pedestals
near the door near the door is this the
door you're fired too i don't didn't
actually hear what you just said I mean
let's not stand on that again actually I
died this so let's not do that I believe
this is the dole what are we doing oh
hey there for outfit true he has the
index you've got to take it from him let
me get these doors go okay here to track
truth if I stay in the network let's do
it oh that's a freeze look but I don't
know what's happened well okay so I'd
itself that but that that could be the
game or could be my xbox i'm unsure
hard to say either way I have been
playing little chunks of all the other
campaigns and haven't had that happen so
I don't know my xbox getting closer
something i am not sure really
I guess that must look weird would be
just swapping between them and not
actually talking about the fact that I'm
swapping between them I like the charge
II once stretch me out man oh stop it
all right we all that ever meet a lot of
a mark right this way yeah suck it
Oh catch up oh just beard it's like a
dwarf but not
ok music seriously nice this is weird
not used to halo something like this in
a strange way when i was playing destiny
it took me a really long time to get
used to the fact that i need to aim and
I think that's because the like first
person shooter they played the Mars has
always been the Halo games where with a
lot of the weapons you don't actually
zoom in that much because most the time
like you can't even shoot when you do so
i'll reverse this Bradman drop that's
fun okay it automatically makes me
bounce then okay doop do you do too